hi there what you're seeing here is a
divide-and-conquer Monte Carlo tree
search in action this is a planning
algorithm that plans in a kind of an
unconventional fashion so we're going to
explore this today in this paper
divide and conquer Monte Carlo tree
search for goal directed planning by
Giambattista poorest condo low and lower
sprucing and list of other authors and I
believe this is from deep mind and Max
Blanc and a da and yeah that's it all
right
so what does this thing do
it is a planning algorithm and planning
might be not really familiar for you so
let's say you are in this room and or
this set of rooms right here there's a
bunch of walls and you are up here and
you want to reach the goal down here so
first of all this is a goal-directed
problem right here it says goal directed
goal directed means that you give the
algorithm a goal to reach and this could
be a different goal each time you run
the algorithm right so you give it a
goal to reach then the second thing here
we see is planning so it is a planning
algorithm what does planning mean
planning means if you're if you
traditionally reinforcement learning
you would think ah I'm just gonna go
ahead and run my my agent here and maybe
you can move in the four different
directions run my agent here do some
things right da da da da maybe I hit a
wall I get a negative reward at try
again in planning you don't have to move
initially what you can do is think about
moving and you can think ahead of what's
going to happen and that's usually
because you have some sort of model what
happens this is very famous applied in
for example alpha go or alpha zero where
you have you know if I move to the right
here I'm going to be here right so you
will know once
reached the goal right if you're if I'm
here I go down I reach the goal cool
so you can think all of this without
actually moving in the environment you
can think yourself ahead what would
happen if I did certain things and that
in turn also means that you can think
ahead multiple different paths so you
can think ed what would happen if I move
right what would happen if I move down
and then you can think in the next layer
if I move right what would happen if I
moved right again what would happen if I
move down instead so you can easily see
the planning problem becomes a tree
search problem in this first in this
case we've done a breadth-first search
right and eventually you'll see that
this will get you to the goal so this
this breadth-first search or maybe you
want to employ a depth-first search
will ultimately get you to the goal we
can represent this as a search tree so
you're here in a particular state and
you have a bunch of actions in this case
for to move left up down or right and
you can choose any of them and you will
get into a new state and from each of
those you could choose and you again and
you can think ahead all of this you can
construct this entire tree and one of
these branches will lead you to the goal
promise what is the problem the problem
is if the path to the goal here is let's
say D steps long then this tree here is
going to be D layers deep and in our
case that means we'll have four to the D
nodes in that tree before we even reach
the goal and that is just a long long or
a big tree and we can't construct all of
it
so algorithms have come along for
example the a-star algorithm where you
can incorporate something like a
heuristic and the heuristic would be
well it's generally good if I'm close to
the goal in l2 distance so you would not
build the entire tree here but you would
prefer nodes that
bring you towards this heuristic so this
note down here is closer to the green
node in terms of l2 distance and this
note down here is even closer but then
you're kind of stuck so a star will
explore a bit probably along this wall
here and once you're here you have a
clear path again right so you can gently
take the actions that minimize this l2
distance so this will already get you to
a real good point Monte Carlo tree
search as it was employed in alphago or
alpha star has a similar structure where
it after a certain while it stops and
evaluates a heuristic to say what's the
the value here and so on so it is in for
some problems an even better method of
constructing the search tree in a way
where you don't get overblown by the
number so the Monte Carlo search tree in
this algorithm refers to the fact that
we are generalizing Monte Carlo tree
search from the let's say the alphago
paper so what's the idea here so far
we've known everything the idea is the
following if I had an Oracle if I am the
master here and I can tell the agent
agent look I guarantee you that this
state right here in the middle you will
pass that state if you want to reach the
goal you will pass this for sure if I
tell this to the agent now what can the
agent do the edge you could say oh ok if
I know that I can simply I don't have to
search for a way to the goal I'd much
rather search for a way from my start
point to that point where I know that
I'm guaranteed to be at someplace and
then I can search also from a way from
there to the goal right so this now you
remember our long our path was D steps
long for the original problem this is
now let's say D half long each of these
paths and that means we just construct
two trees each one of them is going to
be for to the D half and the other one
is also for to the D half and if we add
them that is much smaller than the
original four to the D tree that we
build so right there we have subdivided
our problem into two subproblems and
each of them are much easier than the
original problem this paper basically
does this recursively so it will
subdivide the problem by proposing some
middle state where you are going to be
at some point for sure and that for sure
we're going to take a look at and then
for each of those problems again it will
try to subdivide it into subproblems and
therefore recursively solve these
subproblems until they're small enough
that they can be basically solved in one
step so that's the big idea here and
this is illustrated in this point right
here so you are in this s0 of the start
state and you want to go to this s
infinity the goal state in your case
what this paper does is it proposes to
split the problem here in the middle and
then simply solve the two problems
recursively now what is a bit confusing
right here is that it is the planning
already is a tree search right so a plan
is like a tree but we are searching over
plants so we're searching for the best
plan which means that we are searching
over trees and that search itself is a
tree search so the search itself is a
problem where we go down one route and
then oh no and then we maybe go down
another route and here and then here so
the search is a tree so we're now tree
searching over trees that's the kind of
tricky thing to remember so each of
these plans even if it's half if it's
only half done like this is only half a
plan we don't know what what's gonna
happen in here this half a plan is a
node in the tree that we're searching
over and then it splits it it's
as you can see here into two subproblems
the two subproblems also are nodes in
that search tree so you see that this
top thing here would correspond to this
node even though in itself it is a plan
a tree string in this case and each of
the two subproblems would become these
protect these nodes in the search tree
so keep that in mind as we go through
this paper it is very easy to get
confused in this respect the algorithm
is pretty simple in this case so this
algorithm rests on this traverse
procedure so we're going to we're going
to traverse this what they call these or
nodes so they they divide the problem
into n nodes and/or nodes I I don't
believe that's particularly necessary
for us to think about but here's how
this works
so they traverse the or node s to s
prime this is simply again this is a
node but the node is a path from s to s
prime where we don't know yet what
happens in between right so what we'll
do is we'll run this procedure select
and select it you can see it outputs an
S Prime and the S prime is going to be a
node here somewhere in the middle where
the model says this is your subdivision
point and then it will recursively
traverse the left and the right branch
of this tree so it will subdivide the
problem into two problems and then
recursively call this traverse you see
that's the function that we're defining
call this traverse function on these so
it will subdivide this problem into
these problems and it would for the next
for the next step again it will eat for
each of the problems propose a middle
node and subdivided further and so on
until you have a full plan right at some
point you're going to have
a full plan now here again is the
important thing to remember this is just
one branch of the search this is just
one possible plan and we are going to do
a tree search over these plans so this
select function here it has returned
this as Prime but it could have returned
any point between s and s double prime
so let in it this is just one branch I'm
going to I don't have space to draw here
but I'm going to draw it down here again
so it could have also returned this
particular node here like it's a
different s Prime and then subdivided
the problem into different problems and
then of course those problems are now
different so they would be subdivided
differently again and so on so this top
part here is just if you consider this
thing here your root node this is where
you search from this top part is just
one node one branch in the tree but we
could also subdivide like this and then
that would be another branch in your
tree and this tree here is the thing
that you're searching over it's
important to keep keep this in mind
we're searching over these different
possibilities now the rest of this
algorithm here is basically the carry
over from Monte Carlo tree search and I
don't want to go into that in this video
but if you're interested in you know how
to actually implement this you'll have
to go look at MCTS
and then all of this just carries over
from that algorithm because you have to
keep estimates of value and visit counts
in this tree and so on and also you have
some sort of a value estimator but yeah
I'm mainly concerned with how the tree
is constructed right here so basically
here's the here's the difference between
a between the Monte Carlo tree search
and the divide-and-conquer Monte Carlo
tree search in Mon
Carlo tree search ignore the yellow one
for now you're in the green position and
you want to go to the blue position in
Monte Carlo tree search what you're
searching over is the next action to
take in this case you have four possible
actions to take that's what you're
searching over and that's what you build
your search tree from your search tree
is going to be which action to take
right up left down or right that's why
you have four actions in month in
divide-and-conquer Monte Carlo tree
search you're not searching over actions
you are searching over the best way to
subdivide this problem right you're
searching over which of these all the
black squares should I use to subdivide
my problem into subproblems and that's
what you build your search tree from so
naturally you you can already see what
kind of possibilities do we have here to
subdivide this problem I drew one white
square but any of the black squares are
candidates to subdivide this problem
right any of the of the black squares
could be potential subdivisions and this
is what we search over so in in Monte
Carlo tree search we search over the
actions which gives us this four to the
D tree but in divide and conquer we're
searching over all the ways to subdivide
the problem as you can see there that
are many many more possibilities so from
this first starting node we have like
like a hundred possibilities to
subdivide this problem into two problems
right and each of those again if you now
you've decided on a subdivision let's
say you decided on this one right here
you say I want to pass through that
point on my way to the goal now you have
to subdivide that in this subproblem
into two problems again every possible
black square I'm not saying which one is
good a good thing to subdivide the
problem I'm just asking what is a
possible
candidate every single black square here
is a possible candidate for for a path
from here to here right and again for
this particular subproblem you have to
do the same thing so the the search tree
here even though we said before it is
this one is very deep and this one is
probably only log d so log to d deep its
width is going to be enormous and that
is the catch right the catch this is not
a method that is like a magic pill
the catch is even though your trie is
not as deep it is much much wider and it
is intuitive right because you still
have to have the ability to construct
any possible plan so your trie is going
to have as many nodes as the original
Monte Carlo tree search tree your if you
were to fully expand it right so it's
your trading of depth for width here I
hope I hope that's a bit clearer so your
entire your entire promise of this
method is going to be can you from all
of these possibilities so from all of
these you don't even you don't even want
to go and search even one layer deep
through all of these you don't even want
to consider all of them right you want
to search in this tree you want to limit
your search to very particular ways of
subdivision here if you can do that
efficiently if you can pick efficiently
candidates to subdivide then this could
be a successful thing because your deep
is now not as your tree is not as deep
as the original search tree would have
been and you can limit the width
effectively to only very few candidates
so here we could for example make a
heuristic that will always only pick
squares that are kind of on this
straight path to the goal
so everything rests on how you do this
select action this thing here the entire
algorithm relies on the fact that you
can select effectively select in between
states where you're pretty sure that the
algorithm will have to pass through
there because the worse you make these
predictions the worse your research is
going to work and what they do of course
is they use deep learning as you might
have guessed to do that so they have
they will have a model that for a
particular start and end goal will give
them a probability distribution across
candidates now everything that's black
here also has probability mass but it's
just so small you can't see and these
blue ones are that the lighter blue the
more probable this model thinks that
this is going to be an in-between state
now the tree search can now limit itself
effectively to only the ones here with
the highest probability right so we
select the ones with the highest
probability and will only search plans
that have these as the first possible
subdivisions again we're searching over
plans so we're searching over ways to
subdivide the problem into smaller
problems that is our search space so
once we've decided on one of them let's
say here the yellow one again we have to
evaluate that model for each of the
subproblems and this this is kind of a
step that's missing here so in between
here there would be a model evaluation
that would again tell you which of these
in between states were probable
subdivision candidates and then you
would select again one of those in that
particular search branch and in a
different search branch right you're
searching over these things in a
different search branch you would select
a different one and see is this possibly
a better way to subdivide the problem
and so on so the question of course is
how do you train this model how do you
train a model that gives you good
candidates for subdivision and the
answer here is
comes from the idea of hindsight
experience replay so let's say again you
were here and you want to go here and
you're not very good at at it initially
so they trained this model as I
understand
along with letting their agent act in
this environment so the agent uses the
model to plan but initially it's not
very good
so maybe the agent will fail a lot of
times so instead of going to the Blue
Square it will reach this white square
right here and we'll go here here and
here we'll reach the white square and
instead of saying I failed what you can
do and this is the idea of hindsight
experience replay is to say well I did
fail but I did reach something right I I
have reached a thing and and it's
actually possible that that thing could
have been the goal but this particular
episode this was the goal remember the
goal changes every time it's a
goal-directed policy so it says well
this could have been the goal possibly
so if I just pretend this was the goal
then I have a training example for a
successful run so the hindsight
experience replay basically pretends
that what you have achieved even if you
failed was your actual goal and that
gives you a positive training example
for an episode with that as a goal and
the this it could have been the goal
because the goal is chosen at random so
this gives you a good training example
now this paper just generalizes the
hindsight experience replay or applies
to their particular framework and they
say well if I reach this thing that
means any point on this path is a good
candidate for subdividing the path
because I did actually reach the point
remember the goal is to propose a point
where you're for sure
are going to pass through now since I've
taken this path to this goal I have
passed through any of the squares in
between and so these are my possible sub
candidates and all other black squares I
don't want that so now
have a classifier I can train I can say
any of these squares on my path are good
squares to subdivide and any not on my
path are bad ones they go a step further
I believe and they actually say we're so
if this was M steps we're actually going
to take the particular square that is
reached after M half steps so the exact
middle point of that path is going to be
our training example for subdivision so
you have a classifier that has exactly
one one target to train so this you
train along with acting in the
environment and of course your model for
proposing subdivisions is going to be
better and better and better and better
and that makes your planning algorithm
better and better and that makes you
collect better episodes and so you can
sort of sort of get bootstrap yourself
up this thing now this is the basic
experiment of the paper they also do
this in a 3d manner where they move this
little spider here around so the spider
was trained to just move from one block
to the next book and the planner basic
has to tell it where to go and they show
that they outperform the traditional
Monte Carlo tree search now I have to
say this is cool but you have to
remember this is this is only
advantageous in very very specific types
of problems so first of all it has to be
this goal directed nature otherwise you
probably couldn't train this this
predictor here super well then given
that you have such a good predictor the
problem needs to be such that if you
have a start state there could be many
ways to go about reaching the end and if
you have an end state there could be
many ways from where you could come from
but but there is like some bottleneck
state in the middle where you're pretty
sure that you're going to have to pass
through it so if your problem is of that
nature right if it has
these bottleneck states where you can
predict with reasonable accuracy that
you're going to have to pass through
then this is a good algorithm to
consider and is obviously I mean it's
intuitively outperforming the original
Monte Carlo tree search because you have
much less deep search tree and you can
effectively limit its width by using
that model they also have made this
website where they kind of show videos
of their spider and I've seen it in a
while but it is it is like next to the
mouse if you can see it so so you see
this is kind of a continuous control
problem that also requires planning and
they also have these kind of gifts of
how they're there what order their plans
are constructed in so I invite you to
check this out read the paper if you
like this subscribe leave a like leave a
comment and thank you for listening bye
bye